I'm Lenny Kravitz and this is my pop
culture artifacts collections friends I
go from living here to living in an
Airstream trailer in the Bahamas it's
quite a contrast
I've always thrived on contrasts I
collect a lot of things from the family
things that remind me of my childhood
things remind me of growing up in New
York City and I collect all pop culture
artifacts
the pieces came to me one by one if they
kind of just worked out to I think I
never planned any of this I never plan
to have it
Muhammad Ali James Brown room I got the
dudes from his last fight you know I
would have gotten them just for that but
the fact that that fight was then in the
Bahamas where my family's found it just
made an interesting connection they
actually have some of his blood on them
his DNA is on his phone the shoes I'm
not really a sports collector but this
is about a great human being I have a
poem that was written from Muhammad Ali
to James Brown on the back we have the
address written by Muhammad Ali to James
Brown what he did was he used King James
Brown as the words here that he wanted
to start with and it talks about you
know what he thinks about James Brown
and his appreciation for him and then we
have a picture here of James Brown a
portrait taken by Diane Arbus and by the
way these tusks are not real they are
faux they are made of wood thereby
poochy in the 60s these were a pair of
boots that were worn and belonged to
James Brown these were in his repertoire
he had quite a collection I have many
many pair all over the house
there's just something magical about
James Brown's shoes to me it's almost as
though they have superpowers if you were
to put these on you would be able to
dance like James Brown these are magic
boots so I got all of these things I got
his shoes I got Cameron lyrics and music
you see his font there James Brown
productions and he's
a little picture of James as a kid that
composition was one of my favorites
I had the 45 it's just one of those
tracks this is a mantel where I keep
things that are special to me first we
have a pair of prince's shoes personally
worn his personal tambourine and one of
his guitars my hands that was done by my
Uncle Dave he made these molds and me
put bastard on my hands and made these I
have the watch of somebody's very
special to me very special to my family
his name is Bobby short he called
himself a saloon singer he sang Rodgers
and Hart Gershwin Cole Porter and was a
great interpreter of that music I have
the set list from Woodstock that Jimi
Hendrix wrote right before he went on
songs for Woodstock has the list of
songs what's amazing about that to me is
that Woodstock wasn't Woodstock until it
was finished the legend was after the
fact this is the jumpsuit worn by James
Brown 1974 Zaire Africa rumble in the
jungle
that was the extremely famous fight
where Ali regained his title and James
Brown headlined a concert before the
fight G fos Godfather solo baby
[Music]
well Jimmy Hendrix is this behind the
greatest rock and roll guitar player so
these articles that I have came over
time starting with the purple velvet
pants later into the best in the shirt I
found out that he wore them all at one
time so that another piece of that magic
that happens and I later acquired the
crosstown traffic units and the semister
would stop because aura is five his
music is electricity changed my life it
educated me it turned me off you know
[Music]
John Lennon was another individual that
you know lived his life being an artist
who had no boundaries this is a shirt
that belonged to John Lennon was given
to me by Yoko Ono on my birthday I was
over at the Dakotas and Yoko realized
that it was my birthday and she pulled
me into the room and started going
through these drawers I didn't know what
she was doing she pulled out this shirt
and she said this belonged to John it
was one of his favorites he loved this
shirt here happy birthday beautiful
gesture this to me is the Holy Grail
these are the lyrics of sergeant
pepper's Lonely Hearts Club Band when
Paul wrote it with all the corrections
lyrics that didn't make it this song in
this album changed everything in
rock-and-roll it was such a psychedelic
statement and something that made
everybody think about how they were
gonna improve their game and go further
and you hear how many people sat in
Sergeant Pepper is the day you know
changed everything
for them this is a jacket that was won
by Miles Davis it was given to me by his
wife my godmother Cicely Tyson after he
died she called me over and presented it
to me saying that
miles when you want to be a happy Miles
Davis is a personal one for me because I
started to go see him play live when I
was a teenager I was just blown away and
then I got to know him as a zit as an
adult you know the last time I saw him I
remember we wanted an airplane together
that local rule had been out I just
finished doing the tour and he told me
how proud he was of me that was just
everything for me to hear those words
out of his mouth
uh-huh this is my very first concert it
was the Jackson 5 Madison Square Garden
my father took me to this concert I
remember coming home from school getting
home having dinner and then him saying
he was taking me somewhere I didn't know
where he was taking me we got to the
master garden I still didn't know I
didn't see the sign and it couldn't see
what was going on the lights went out
and the Jackson 5 came on and I lost my
mind that was the turning point the next
morning I knew exactly what I wanted to
do this is so special to me because of
what it is and my father took this and
it was the moment that changed my life
my father was a very interesting and
complex man he was a lover of music in
the arts and you know I have articles of
both of my parents I had my father's
shoes upstairs that he wore to work
I have his glasses I have a stopwatch
you only see
this wristwatch it's just beautiful to
keep the spirit of my folks with me I
don't have them physically but I have
the memories I have the energy that they
left this is the first television that
my parents had in our apartment in New
York City I don't know how this got
saved throughout the years it's by
singer who made sewing machines we all
used to sit around being three of us and
watch TV
there's the speaker and there was the
channel change with the little numbers
on it this is this is my first memory of
television and of all the shows I
watched as a kid tying back to Muhammad
Ali my parents went to the Ali Frazier
fight the first one master square garden
which was you know the fight of the of
the world I couldn't go I was too young
but they brought me back those gloves
which were part of the merchandise those
were in my room as a child my entire
life I then put the gloves away wherever
they ended up
I found them years later I pulled them
out and I had one glove set to each
fighter in Naples I'm one good loves
send them back to me
so they're our childhood memory I used
to play with them their historical
memory from these from two of the
greatest fighters of all time
[Music]
of course everything is always it's it's
family stuff you know from James Brown
Bob Marley to John Lennon to the Beatles
to Jimi Hendrix to Muhammad Ali to the
television the marbles the my hands cast
by my uncle these are all things that
made me that influenced me
[Music]